we had talked about it these are the
factors that make people have
to leave their homes although they preferred
not to do so but they only advertise in them
the 5 lucas immigration yesterday fabri has it
in the look so that nothing to me
each person is from the city
the corruption and  the lack of good
governance as well as violence
against women indigenous peoples
people the axis of cv and also people of
African descent
determine the effect and we want to
work with you to address
pressing challenges factors and root causes
offer hope
that the people of  guatemala stay in
your homes fire the spirit of mind
award is of the position this semester is the
collective in the type in hernani we will see
in what type
and of course the underlying reason for
all this is that the American continent
is our home and its peoples are
ours  neighbors including the people of
Guatemala and nearby nations and it is
very important that we
take this  as a responsibility to
work together
in the face of pressure from manet my gration
in the effective sector in jimena
united states proposes plans to increase aid
in the region strengthen cooperation
to manage migration in an
effective, safe and humane manner
efe
and in addition to  the efforts that we are
making bilaterally and
multilaterally and with the united states
a comprehensive strategy is being built with
international allied institutions
around the world foundations the
private sector and also community organizations
sánchez dresses whittle and also tomorrow
I am going to meet with
community leaders  Guatemalan and I am very
anxious to know what their ideas are
because what we have to think about is
that people always have to be at the
center of everything we do,
kutcher purposes, I think that with this,
we all have to
participate together, not only  political will is going to be
needed but also
the hard work so that
we can offer a promising future
in exchange for maintenance well
actually mr president once again it is
an honor to be able to meet with you today and
I hope to be able to travel to your country soon and
how are the plans now we believe that you
will  be in the month of June
thank you very much
in huesca strange for this
meeting in which we will deal without hesitation without hesitation
with multiple issues that are of interest
to both countries
and if they finally did it, they are
totally is the generation of hope
and that creation of hope to  through
the consolidation of walls of prosperity
that allow us to make sure that people
here find the opportunity to get
ahead without having to think about the
usa is actually the final path that
should be our goal
at bayern
opportunity your whole wife because I don't
I upload United 6 the show
and in that sense, you can be sure, Madam
Vice President, that in the government of
Guatemala we have a lot in  interest in
being partners with the united states in the goals we have in
common is that we have to be able to
eradicate not poverty but
could eradicate the causes that are the
origin of many of our ills
commented that the ship 99 that 11 are and
we are going to explain when the  heard you speak
the way you do it by
putting and putting the human being
as the center and the axis of the actions,
I have no choice but to congratulate myself with that
position
6500 because it is something that we forget
that here what we have to fight for is
for the preservation of the lives of all
the members and the
economic stability of all the members of the
country, regardless of their ethnic origin,
but regarding the fact that we are Guatemalans and
that we all have the right to live with
equality
[Applause]
and even in that stadium the sounders  of
camps it was due to an order to
try to put
in order
if they are not wang and I am really glad
to be able to deal with you I hope to see you here
in Guatemala in the month of June from here
to  he month of June we should
propose to have a road map
drawn up that can serve to
reach government-to-government agreements so that
we can not only begin the
hard road that lies ahead
of us to achieve peace, progress and
development  of the country but also to
count on your collaboration on
the issues that we need to be
strengthened
software wow jamaran bytes de sánchez
many times is underway